you like wrestling nwa sure cuz my
grandfather my great I was raising the
bootleg house so he loved wrestling like
my friend I was born in 1905 and now I
realized he's probably kind of racism
because every time they like done the
boat paddle so beat up the white roses
like a cracker he loved it and I got
into a real heavy - yes I used to love
it when I was coming up we were you
raised in Georgia I was raising and and
that's why they shouted it right at a
little look in the back of the Omni is
not there anymore but I I remember cuz I
the ticket was $5 and I told his story
last night and I used to like straight
pup $5 ago you know I was [ __ ] poised
hell but one time I was walking downtown
on P Street and his white dude thought I
was older and you know cuz I had big
boobs big but he was like hey come go
into my room and I'm like oh okay and I
got up there I had never been in the
hotel room he had AC and I didn't know
if the [ __ ]
and it was so cold in here and his
frigerator had like real drinks you know
like coca-cola I'm used to kool-aid and
[ __ ] colas he just laid on the bed
he'd grabbed my hand and told me to
Jackie's penis I didn't know what jacket
when I just went up and down and up and
there and when I finished he gave me
$100 I was like you want me to come back
tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I got a [ __ ] front row seat and the
wrestling met with the white people with
popcorn and hot dog I felt so [ __ ]
privileged
that's exactly how Sam gets his seats
right we have a wrestler here I think we
should bring our I didn't know he only
had a few minutes left all right
looking back then for the record for
everybody all over the internet for all
this audience
everybody knows who just called the
wrestler out right why wouldn't I am for
Wii so when it win okay so when it
disintegrates into what its Amelia hello
[Applause]
looks like he's hustling the audience
right now trying to get $20 for photos
got ten minutes left
star of the website lonely Virgil net
Virgil I heard a rumor that you were
trying to hustle people out of money at
the airport here in Montreal true or
false true or false
damn right Meredith
Virgil sets up shop like Virgil is no
wrestling himself but unlike any other
old wrestler Virgil will set up shop
wherever he is and try to sell
eight-by-tens and photos to whoever's
there so he'll do it in a subway station
in an airport wherever he's at just to
credit it try to get a little extra that
[ __ ] money I believe it's called yeah
yeah you bet their ass on that there
good good yeah what'd you do last night
Virgil everywhere I go I'll try to make
that money man
what kind of money is good that's that
meat sauce money that's right what the
book is meat sauce
question miss path well you don't have
an answer for that question
what is it what the [ __ ] is a heat so I
think I've been to many times
I'll put the meat sauce all of my body
moves number I beat his ass take this
week miss miss pan is saying that
physically she could best you hey I like
I like what she's talking about
okay yeah okay Virgil I like their big
asses man sitting next to one he's got
back teeth
[Applause]
right
not applause for Virgil he's dead
because it's [ __ ] bag virgin no miss
Pat wants to know how old you are me
yes you 50 you are 50 you can lie to
these white people but you can't lie to
me I'm not yes you for your trick a
white person age you wouldn't it be they
say when they line I be anything you
want me to be virgins about 65 years old
this [ __ ] just told me wrestle
with the arm stromberg brothers and out
every day so I know he's strong brothers
yeah guys they called Dwayne Johnson
rock you never ran it Steve off the
towel when he got her three old man and
him with him yes you did you weren't
even in the company at this height
sweatpants
hey what are you doing at the Comedy
Festival tonight are you wrestling
tonight on the main stage of the comedy
[Music]
[Laughter]
scene with mr. Joel is the star of his
own website called lonely Virgil net
it's a made up mainly of photos of
Virgil sitting at conventions and
autograph sessions with no line around
him I could believe that yeah I've
watched
n:w I've never heard a virgin never
you've know I mean you just named
Russell she's never heard of Virgil
before no is that a surprise to you
Virgil no you don't know to myself
that's right I guess not I remember you
match it to rock it was great
never it never hates high driving
general version Colin what's happened
what on earth is happening we know you
didn't arouse them I mean we come down
wrestle with the rock okay
that's impossible by the way the stadium
lighting is starting to flicker this is
that's not many lives virgin I'm told
that what's going on
I trained Dwayne Johnson that's right
now you trying to raise them that's
right but you didn't wrestle direct yes
she does yeah I thought Pat Patterson
trained well no Pat Patterson knew him I
trained you oh yeah you notice the radio
show and people can hear you lying
I know people people know I'm telling
the truth